oui rebecca rumi a conduit la maladie et
deux fois même trois si l'on compte la
spina bifida
malformations sur la colonne vertébrale
avec laquelle elle née mais de ce
parcours médical elle a choisi d'en rire
d'en faire frire j'ai un humour un peu
dans la dérision sarcastique un peu
humour noir j'ai pas peur de me moquer
de moi même je connais les hôpitaux du
pitch tout petit et d'ailleurs je le dis
dans mon spectacle les hôpitaux sont ma
résidence secondaire
ce que j'y ai passé beaucoup de temps
j'ai dû de cancers lymphome et le
feeling greffe de moelle osseuse avec
moins d'heures life rebecca a fait le
choix d'écrire son histoire la chimio
les effets secondaires des traitements
mais pas de pathos pour celle qui a fait
l'école du one man show à paris c'est
vraiment quelque chose que j'ai écrit
avec mon coeur
qui me confirme qu' une partie de ma vie
j'ai une ville et un petit peu atypique
je dirais que c'est un peu ma thérapie
théâtrale et j'ai fait de délivrer un
message aux gens c'est à dire que même
si on a des ennuis dans la vie que
chaque fois des petits comme des gros
tracas ou des épreuves difficiles bien
il faut toujours garder espoir que l'on
peut s'en sortir que la médecine n'est
pas une science exacte écrit pendant
trois ans après sa rémission est rendu
aussi difficile par la crise de la copie
de vos rondeurs life et mis en scène par
delphine grand rebecca remy a pu créer
et répéter en résidence à
villennes-sur-seine sur proposition de
la ville avant de jouer à paris
je fus monté sur le nez de la vie j'ai
enfilé les gants qu'on me barth énergie
en mairie lagarde